to take on something like Blade Runner
this is you know this is obviously a
very deeply personal moving for people
I'm sure it was for you as well so what
was it that made you decide you know
you're up for the challenge you wanted
to make it happen I didn't want somebody
else to [ __ ] it up that's the best
picture I've ever heard that is
legitimately the best answer I've ever
heard because you thought it no but it's
like it's all of my favorite movie of
all time I grew up with this movie and
it's like it's truer and and and it's
part of my the birth when I decided to
be a filmmaker the it's part of the
birth of that desire that dream it was
the movie was there and I couldn't say
no but I didn't say yes Punta Islita
it's not a easy task it was a big
challenge but we had a lot of fun and
was he doing it and can you talk a
little bit about working with Ridley
Scott and and just what what that
process was like a little bit but I
thing is that the best way to work with
Ridley to his work it was that it was
far away because the thing is that it
really was very generous at the
beginning he explained to me what were
is in sparing source of inspiration for
the first movie but I already did
what were the idea the main ideas behind
it the creativity process of it and then
he left me alone he said it's your
movies your responsibility if you need
me and be there otherwise I'll be away
that was the best gift he could give me
because I would not have been able to
direct a movie with images behind my
batter but not that have been possible
am I saying excellent and so Harrison
what made you decide to come back to
Blade Runner because I think if people
saw Blade Runner movie without you in it
they would go well it's not a real Blade
Runner movie so what was it what why was
it important for you to be involved well
we have a we had a really good script
and based on a really good idea and it
it deepened the understanding of my
character that had my character had very
strong emotional relationships other
characters in the film and and I I think
I felt when I read the script that had
had great depth and
fantastic opportunity I was delighted to
be involved Ryan Gosling how does this
[Laughter]
how is this different for you Ryan from
other sci-fi movies and you know when
when you when you read it the vision of
it what was it that that you saw going
into it and what did it mean to you
orig seeing the original of this
I mean having seen the original going
into this and differentiating it from
other you know dystopian sci-fi film
what was it that was special about it to
you I mean there's there's so much that
makes the film special you know I think
somatically it's really I just remember
when I saw it when I was a kid I was
really it was one of the first films
that I'd seen it it wasn't clear how it
was supposed to feel when it was over
and it was very hard to distinguish the
hero from the villain it's there's a
moral ambiguity to it that's a quite a
haunting experience and of course
visually and you know just thematically
and the performances there's just
something really magical happened in
that film and you know as a fan I was
just excited to hear that they were
going to continue the story and then to
be a part of it was you notice - just an
incredible opportunity and then to get
to work with any one of these people you
hope to have that in your career but to
get to work with all of them at the same
time it's just it's like being on a
football team with the Avengers or
something you know we're going to be
good hmm maybe a football team with the
Justice League
[Applause]
I think that's what there was a little
bit of an audio glitch probably I'd
never a question for Harrison which you
know you don't answer this we don't like
a question but uh but but I loved that
the themes of Blade Runner is really
exploring the idea of our relationship
to technology and especially now since
the first one came out we are so much
more reliant on technology do you have
any thoughts on any of the ethical ideas
behind this yeah I mean it shown the
original film explored the ethics of of
the creation of replicants and and their
utility and we further developed those
themes in the story but I'm not going to
tell you anything about it ok ok no you
don't have to yeah I could come over and
tickle you until you hit something
bring it up
[Applause]
host the presenter Chris Hardwick is
brutally murdered today inside Hall age
that was awkward
awkwardly attractive I wonder if anyone
else whatever anyone else has any more
ideas Lenny who I adore what Walking
Dead is about as big a show as you can
have on television but have you and even
though you've worked on other films have
you worked on anything of this scale
before no and and I don't believe I'm
here and this is happening it was yeah
up until now I didn't even know that we
were going to get this far I can't
believe it happened because it happened
in a time for me anyways it was like a
little gift that was kind of given it
happened in a tiny little window that it
had to fit in in the middle of shooting
The Walking Dead and I flew off the
Budapest and I shot this thing and I
came back and I went back into killing
zombies and then then I got a phone call
and Here I am that's fantastic and then
for Sylvia rana any experiences working
on the film that you want to share
before we go to audience questions
anything that was exciting to you I mean
like what was I mean for me everything
was exciting I mean to begin with
working with with this old geniuses here
it was mind-blowing and the whole thing
the whole experience from rehearsals to
you know working you know seeing the
costumes trying them on like a lot of
work with with our hair department and
makeup on and everyone it was so cool to
see how the character was coming you
know alive and and then every day on set
was amazing actually
I'm sure people have audience questions
so we'll throw the questions for a
couple minutes hi what's your name hi
there my name is Cindy I'm from Columbia
I came all over there from there to here
super nervous Ryan I love you so much
thank you so much for being here so my
question is for the cast if you could
give any advice to your character what
will it be
thank you any any bytes to an actor you
said any advice to an actor cast the
entire cast oh the entire cast yes okay
I could give any advice to the cast to
your character your character don't
mistakenly go in Harrison's trailer huge
mistake
good advice thank you for the question
yeah it might be a difficult question to
answer without giving anything away you
know without without revealing anything
but but thank you thank you for coming
hi what's your name hi I'm Jonah and
what I was wondering was that it's been
a while since the original blade blade
runner' just came out so I am said I'm
very nervous and what I was wondering is
that what was that what did it feel like
like that kind of surreal moment like
when did it sink in like we're doing
blade blade runner' again like when did
it really sink in that's actually really
great question yeah because obviously
you know you go you go to work and you
you're like oh I got a job I got to
learn this stuff I'm gonna but there
must have been a moment where it really
started to sink in what it was that you
were doing I'm not sure that it has sunk
in yet I'm not sure this isn't like a
giant elaborate episode of Punk'd that
I'm a part of somehow no honestly it was
it's so surreal because you grow up
watching this film it's such an iconic
film the universe is not isolated to the
film itself it's been it's been borrowed
from and inspired so many other movies
it's just it's so expansive and then to
the point where it you know it's sort of
felt like it then enveloped us and we
were in it and walking around in this
these incredible locations and and and
it's really it's really hard to to
describe that that feeling and it really
hasn't quite sunk in yet I think it's
time for one more question before we
have to let everyone go what's your name
sir I'm Adam hey Adam what's your
question it's for
person Ford is your life goal to reboot
every major franchise you helped to
create like Blade Runner you bet your
ass
I think that
[Applause]
theatres October 5th please pity
Broadway every handsome boy go protest
Harrison Ryan in Sylvia thank you so
much for being here thank you